- I'm hanging out with Cheryl Burke
and we've got Cecily Strong
on Skype from Vancouver.
(crowd cheering)
Everybody's here.
It's a party.
My next guest is someone you've seen
and laughed with on the shows
"Outsourced" and "Crazy Ex-Girlfriend."
His new show is called "Connecting"
and you can see it Thursdays
on NBC. Take a look.
- And now my children won't eat anything
but Woody Harrelson branded
vegan Mac and Cheese, or..
- Woody Harrelson's vegan chicken fingers
I'm Visage's godfather and
I take pride in knowing her
bougie vegan food preferences.
- There is no Woody's Mac and Cheese
left anywhere in Los Angeles.
- Just order some online.
- I did,
and this is what I got, a box
of loose, broken spaghetti
and a bag of either tang
and ranch dressing mix
or expired cocaine.
- (indistinct) So please welcome,
Parvesh Cheena, everybody.
(upbeat music)
I wish I could!
- Hugs, first!
- Oh my God, you're funny.
- Hi everybody. Hi, hi, hi.
- Hi, here's my first question.
Well, first of all, you
already know Cecily apparently.
- I do. Isn't that crazy?
- Do you know Cheryl?
- Hi, Cheryl. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Okay so no, you said nice to meet you.
(group laughing)
Gotcha.
How, how did I do? Be honest.
How did I do pronouncing your name?
- Honestly, you were great.
- Okay.
- Seriously. And it's such
a thing like, you know,
when you have an ethnic name, like...
- It's awesome.
I just am not used to
saying a name like that.
- Like Parvesh?
- So I was like, am I going
to royally butcher this?
- No, not at all.
I've gotten so many things
over the years, like Parvert.
- Oh, that's not, that's not..
- [Parvesh] It's middle school kids but..
- That's playground, yeah.
- But do you know what I love?
Was I got Parmesan cheese
for Parvesh Cheena,
but it worked because you know, Chicago.
And I'm made out of pizza anyway.
- Oh my God.
- Hi Cecily. It's so great to see you.
- You too.
- Actually, wait, speaking of Cecily.
So, we just, earlier we played a clip
of a PSA that Cecily was in and
I swear, can we actually see that again?
Cause there's the ending.
- Here, we got languages and stuff.
- Yo tengo que fumar.
- Hey dude, I am smoke.
- Hey, I am smoke.
- [Parvesh] That was me.
That was, that was me.
That was my very first
commercial with Cecily.
And I'm much older than her.
So she was, I think,
were you in high school?
- Yeah, yeah. I was a
junior in high school.
- And I was like, I think
a junior in college.
So it was my first commercial.
And I think you named me in it.
I think like there's like one take when,
Cecily got my name right, too.
She was like, Oh, that's Parvesh.
And I'm like, "Hey, good."
- Hey, I like her.
- Yeah.
- I just love you that
you said "I am smoke."
(group laughing)
That's awesome.
- Yeah, my accident work.
I've been doing it for decades.
- [Kelly] It was amazing.
- I mean, we met before we even realized
we did that together.
And then I think I saw it
on the internet was like,
Oh my God.
- Yeah, you texted me.
Like after we had met,
you texted me, like,
I think this is you. And I'm like it is.
And it was just..
- [Kelly] How random is that?
- Because it was..
- [Cecily] Isn't that bizarre?
- But you know what?
Like your first job,
you're just so scared.
So I don't remember
too much from that day.
And so it was just like so
surreal, like, Oh my God.
Cecily from TV was that,
that kid who was like
leading this commercial?
- Far from TV.
- No, but wait, you have a
new show "Connecting," right?
- [Parvesh] I do.
- I love this. So, what
is connecting about?
- Well, connecting is very topical.
It's one of the..
It's a Zoom comedy about, you know,
all of us with the stay at home orders,
the pandemic right now.
And there'd been a couple of them,
but this is an ongoing series
that'll be on NBC Thursday nights.
And, it's a group of seven friends and
just living life and I am the dad
and who works in PR
and is having a little
trouble problem with his kids.
You know? How is it with you?
- Toddlers are fun when you're
working from home, everybody.
- Yeah.
- So wait, so what's the hardest part
about doing the show from
your living room though?
- Well, I'm kind of,
I'm still kind of getting used
to being out in the world.
This is like maybe my second day
like being around more than two people.
- Yeah.
- I'm one, I'm one of those
like strict people at home.
- I'm strict.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And we, I mean, like,
I feel like I'm an expert on like
wiring and sound and lighting.
We do it all.
Like my partner, he, when
he's home from his normal job,
he might help, barely.
He's like, I need to rest, too.
I'm like, okay, let me light this.
And like, but we do everything:
makeup, hair, wardrobe.
- [Kelly] Nope.
- And then last minute,
oh, and don't forget your one
page monologue you have to do.
- Right. You're everything.
So it's the acting is the
last thing we worry about.
So I'm just playing this
character, just like myself.
- I literally,
I thought that I was going
to get fired once this hit
because it like, cause it was like,
I'm not doing hair and
makeup. I was like..
- Well on Dancing,
- Mama's coming on screen.
- On Dancing, it's the same thing.
- And it is what it is.
I don't like doing it.
So I was like, well,
if no one can be here,
- [Cheryl] Oh well!
- Sorry for you, America.
- I do feel bad sometimes
like the guys don't always have to.
And, I know it's a new world
where everyone can wear every
makeup, everything, but I
just never was that person.
And I just even popping
into your lovely vanities
department, the hair and makeup people,
they just give a quick.
- No, they give you that
Harry Potter touch up
that you're like what
happens? It's me in color.
- [Parvesh] I just felt
like, am I in a spa again?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like it feels like to
be pampered by someone
doing your hair and
makeup again after like
months of just like, oh gosh.
Oh, that zit, I got to cover that.
- So, everybody you can watch
connecting Thursdays on NBC.